[Music]
I had never I mean I've been following
you for a long time but I'd never seen
you perform before and I was deeply
impacted by it but I think the thing
that moved me the most was just the love
from the audience like the connection is
so deep with your peeps yeah yeah well
it's a long-term relationship we've had
yeah you know I wouldn't be able to do a
show like this if I didn't have an
audience that I had grown up with for so
long yeah I mean it's it's it's no small
thing and it was it was very very
evident the amount of love that was that
was moving in two directions yeah you
know and four hours for half yeah I do
like I do I'm an athlete I do like ultra
distance stuff like ultra marathon type
stuff that was the ultra endurance
version of Amanda Palmer last night well
and ironically I I feel that the show
should be a little longer mm-hmm yeah I
had to rush to get to curfew I didn't
get to play the Encore right um and you
know I I in the original draft at the
show I had more songs and stories they
had to get cut and cut and cut yeah yeah
yeah well I loved it I loved everything
about it and I'm delighted to be able to
talk to you today so thanks for making
time I'm really glad you came
yeah radical compassion is what I want
to talk about if you're open to it when
we were when Greg and I were chatting
during the intermission Greg said
something I think is totally on point
which is that you can't be radically
compassionate on the level that you are
without the vulnerability or the
willingness to be as vulnerable as you
are it's yeah interesting
kind of how you think about that well I
think I think compassion and
vulnerability just sort of go hand in
hand and you know I also think that the
thing that makes radical compassion
radical is that by definition you can't
be selective about it right I mean this
is the thing and this is what I see in
the feminist movement all the time too
it's like you can't decide to be
compassionate you know just for those
people or just in this moment mm-hmm or
you know I'll be compassionate if
everything lines up for me if it's
convenient whatever and you know in
order to empathize with somebody anybody
especially the difficult people and by
the difficult people that could be the
strange people in strange lands that you
have very little in common with
culturally or your mom mm-hmm
you know the the leaps of compassion
that are the most difficult do take a
certain kind of vulnerability because
it's in that moment where you're sort of
opening yourself up to potential harm or
or actually fear yeah it's like the fear
of what's gonna happen if you open
yourself up to empathizing with this
person or what's going to happen in your
own head if you open your imagination up
to empathizing with someone who could do
something terrible to you yeah yeah
being willing to embrace the fringes of
what our social contract is willing to
endure right the idea that we can all
agree that compassion is a good thing
and everyone likes to think of
themselves as compassionate but how
sturdy is that concept you know and your
willingness to test that at the outer at
the outer at the outer edges of it is
you know what leads to poem gate and
then that's where you're tested like
you're resolved like is your compassion
truly radical enough to withstand the
criticism not just from people from a
different political perspective but your
own people yes well your own people
failing to have compassion for you or
your failure to have compassion for the
people immediately around you I mean I
feel like those were the most difficult
moments yes so so maybe explain like the
poem thing briefly for people that are
listening that might not be familiar
with what what went down
in 2013 I'm from Boston and so in the
spring of 2013 my husband Neal and I
were renting a place in Boston not far
from my apartment we had just gotten
together a relationship that was still
pretty new and we had moved to Boston
because my best friend had cancer and I
was taking him to chemo and the Boston
bombing happens a few blocks from my
apartment where I had lived for many
many many years and I mean I guess do
you want the long story the medium story
or the short story well you know flight
to catch so we should go maybe the
indium yeah well there's the there's a
lot of layers but the I think the most
important thing is you know I live on
the internet a lot my community gathers
on the internet and when the Boston
bombing happened this is also 2013 so I
was on Twitter a lot yeah and we were
all told by the government to stay in
our houses I mean everyone was literally
told don't go outside and the news was
horrific I mean there's literally a
bloodbath at the marathon finish line
and it was it was just sort of
unimaginable like nothing like this had
ever happened in Boston this was a mass
murderer and and and it was then the
images were particularly horrific you
know these limbless dying people and the
manhunt going on at the same time I
don't know if you remember the news but
you know there's a city lockdown a
manhunt for this kid
and this kid till hurt tsarnaev was 19
and I grew up in Lexington he grew up in
Cambridge you know the next town over
and it was so close to home like the
idea that this you know this kid just
like me from a lefty liberal town could
carry out an act so horrific and he was
friends with kids of my friends like
this was someone from my community and
we followed as the manhunt happened and
you know I finally found him he was
found bleeding in the bottom of a boat
hiding in someone's backyard in
Watertown and I i I'd to imagine what it
must have been like at that moment to be
that kid I mean he was a kid he was 19
and he had just murdered a bunch of
people and was just lying there waiting
to be caught and I wrote this
spur-of-the-moment poem on my blog
trying to you know not even so much
trying to empathize but just sort of
doing this exercise of imagination like
what is it like to be in the bottom of
that boat um and I got crucified by the
Boston press for even daring to offer up
what appeared to be empathy for this
care did you have a sense that that
could be perceived in that way or did
that take you by surprise I was totally
shocked yeah and also you know I did it
to my blog which is not a blog with a
huge readership and to a very specific
set of people you know my my tribe my
community many of whom um had been with
me on Twitter for the past few days
watching this unfold you know we were
all holding each other in this really
horrifying moment and this was mostly
for them and the the poem actually sort
of stitched together my own feelings of
lostness and confusion in the world with
this kids which i think was what people
found mostly offensive
and you know the first comment sent on
my blog were from my fan base my
community and and you know people read
it they liked it they understood it but
then you know when the outside world got
ahold of it and this crazy right-wing
blog found it and put it up I was all of
a sudden branded you know a terrorist
sympathizer and and there were lots of
very very very very very nasty words and
languages that I do not want to repeat
but do you think part of that was due to
timing or I think you know like if you
had done that a year later or yeah if I
had done it a year later I don't think
anyone would have cared but this was
ministers like three or four days after
the bombing so it hurt of course a
little bit to get yelled at by all these
right-wing people but what-what really
hurt was getting yelled at by my own you
know by the left-wing people who you
know screamed at me that this was
inappropriate and too soon and
especially what hurt the most was that
you know Amanda we get that you believe
in radical compassion and that's great
but there are people who we do need to
exclude right it begs the question of
whether compassion is a zero-sum game
like if your apportioning compassion to
one person does that mean that you are
neglecting compassion for somebody else
and is compassion tantamount to to
endorsements well that's where it gets
sort of confused and it's not and I mean
this was my defense and I you know I
felt so wildly misunderstood and you
know the first thing I did is I put my
hand up and I was like you guys you guys
you guys you do get that I do understand
what just happened mm-hmm and my friend
Dylan Marin he was at his own great
podcast it's called conversations with
people who hate me and he connects
people with their internet trolls and
haters it's a really beautiful podcast
and he has a great maxim that empathy is
never endorsement yeah empathy is not
endorsement empathy is just empathy
and you know and you've got I mean the
more I think about these sorts of things
and the more I look at it from you know
through different facets we have to have
compassion for the worst people well I
think we're we're in a cultural moment
right now where these how we talk about
these things has become so highly
sensitized as we retreat into our silos
and you know virtue signal to our
respective audiences and what's kind of
interesting is the juxtaposition of that
kind of cultural Gestalt and in that
direction versus your relationship with
Twitter which is like this incredibly
positive you know community oriented
kind of collective experience that right
raises the vibration of all the people
that you touch an impact yet at the same
time there's this other you know
ecosystem that's going on on that same
platform that's contributing to the
problem that ultimately you had to kind
of weather through yeah and that's a
fear driven system mm-hmm so what's the
antidote keep to just doubling down on
yeah and and you know it's it can be
very tempting mm-hmm to give in to you
know anchor judgment that's silo that
you were talking about but it never
works it doesn't it never pans out well
yeah but we're just seeing it
continually amplifying like 10x every
year yep yeah so what do we just need
more Amanda Palmer's on Twitter I guess
well actually it might be useful to
mention that I did not come by that
immediately um I learned you know I've
been on the internet since 1999 and the
the early Dresden Dolls blog you know
Steve you know soon had a forum and this
was a pre Facebook pre-twitter pre
myspace even pre live journal like in
the the order days of the Internet
and I learned I learned gradually that
feeding you know feeding the monsters of
hate and judgment on the internet were
not really yielding good fruit and I
learned these lessons through my blog
you know and through all of a sudden
through the power that I wielded having
this platform I learned it on Twitter
and I would probably be pretty ashamed
of some of the things that I posted in
the early days because I just didn't get
it yet you know and I and I I didn't
fully understand yet the importance of
not telling other people's stories for
them I didn't understand yet the
importance of not you know like
immediately picking up my sword when
someone was challenging me and and go
and having a go at them
I was very reactive and years and years
and years on the Internet of and also
you know my own work and my own
mindfulness work finally led me to like
realizing that there's a kind of a
jujitsu yeah that you can do without
leaving the internet and without saying
[ __ ] everything I am deleting all my
social media there is a way of reaching
back out to people to to D charge a
situation you know to neutral laws to
neutralize and you know the best what's
the word I'm looking for you know the
best weapon really can often just be
burying your own throat and showing your
own vulnerability to someone who's
charging at you because they're never
expecting that yeah and when people are
coming at you with intense hatred
they're never expecting that you're just
gonna calmly try to engage them in a
loving conversation right yeah wait what
what what you just changed the rules
here yeah and I I like that practice you
know that's not something I was ever
to get good at when I got into rock and
roll but that wound up being a kind of a
side-effect you know of being a public
musician on the internet how do you feel
about the the kind of hair-trigger that
we seem to be on in this kind of
canceled culture where misstep you know
can result in you know basically the
ruination of somebody for something they
said or something that gets me I think
it's very dangerous
yeah and in a lot of instances very
stupid mm-hmm and it's a reality sure I
mean it is a reality and they're there
it is important to keep our hand on the
throttle of you know what gets amplified
who gets attention what we consume you
know what stories we want to continue to
tell and who gets to tell them yeah so I
would never say like let's just keep it
a free-for-all and and not be discerning
but to just cancel everything that has a
whiff of badness would basically I mean
ultimately if we took that to its
endgame the cancellation of all art and
I'm not an I'm not a fan of that yeah
yeah because nothing is pure it doesn't
exist mmm and the compassion is the is
the facility and the willingness to be
able to see the whole person beyond the
misdeed sure and I and you know part of
our job and part of our job you and I
anyone with a platform as media makers
culture makers is to always add context
you know this is what this is this is
where this came from we have the
internet we can [ __ ] put anything in
context if we're not lazy right and so
you know something of dubious origin
let's say a short film directed by a
serial killer it can still have its
place in society but it means
to be put into context we need to talk
about why are we watching this what is
it what does it mean what can it teach
us um if it has nothing to teach us [ __ ]
it throw it out burn it good but if it
has got something to teach us and
usually almost always it does we need to
be more careful curators of what culture
is and is going to be and that means not
just throwing everything in the dumpster
yeah an appreciation for subtlety in
context right like we've just decided
that that context is not important you
know as long as it serves my you know
agenda or whatever it is that you know I
stand for well like everything else in
culture right now there's like there's a
death of nuance yeah right well and a
death of a death of satire and in death
of irony and that's not good for no it's
not it's not last night you said in
there was criticism in the wake of this
poem situation and part of the criticism
was that you were you were you were
accused of like making light and you
said that's my job my job is to the job
of the artist is to make light and you
then wrote this other like this other
more recent poem reflecting back on that
same individual in Boston and you it was
the most beautiful thing you said we
will stay crippled in the darkness if we
cannot feel compassion for the heart
that is the darkest I really did rhyme
darkness with dark it still it's still
pretty [ __ ] good though I loved that
and I think we need more of that yeah I
will double down on that any day yeah I
mean how do you beyond you know making
light like how do you define the role of
the artist I don't that's not my job
yeah how do you think of it for yourself
though like if you're to elaborate on
that uh I mean
an artist's job is to is to offer up
some form some kind of reflection of
what's going on what's going on out
there what's going on inside us what's
going on inside me right now and to
organize it in some kind of way
you know whether that is painting dance
sculpture film music you name it to
organize that reflection into an
offering back to everybody else you
might see you in this this might make
you feel something you might recognize
yourself in this and you know the I find
my so especially lately I've been
working through so much my own grief
through making art that I find myself
wondering like like what the [ __ ] to
other people do like I'm really lucky I
have a full-time job where I get to like
work through and try to make meaning of
what is happening to me I get to spend
all day and night doing that but most
people would would would think of that
as a nightmare like most people spend a
lot of energy trying to like erect a
wall in between themselves and whatever
that is well I'm most voiding looking at
that mostly that doesn't work no it
doesn't but people will pursue it to the
grave yeah and mostly it doesn't work
hmm you've got a sort through you've got
to make meaning you've got to um you
know when grief happens there has to be
space and time to heal it could be
through you know through through any
form of exercise or creation but you
have to do it if you don't do it and you
compartmentalize we see what happens
we're seeing it all over the place
yeah it was was it was Anthony who said
to you that
those issues left unattended are doing
push-ups in the dark yeah you said if
you don't deal with your grief and
trauma or your demons they go into the
cellar of your soul and lift weights
mm-hmm yeah I've experienced that we all
have yeah you've got a deal
yeah when I when I look at like what you
do and all your various expressions
though it's it's it's almost like you
Amanda Palmer the person transcends the
art like you are the art right like do
you see the distinction between the
offering and just you as who you are I
think you're I think your person is art
in its own sense like just you know just
everything that you are and you know in
like a Warhol Ian sense like you are the
expression of all of these things you're
a representation of all of these
offerings but it's a performance in its
own right you know I would say if that's
true it's no more or less true for me
than it is for you or anyone else in
this room what do you mean by that I
mean we're always performing our own
lives all of us yeah you know this gets
into a really heavy-duty philosophical
rabbit hole of you know what's real
which one of you is real like this one
the one who woke up in the morning the
one who was brushing his teeth the one
who is visiting with his family like
which is you know which one is persona
and which one is real well we're all
multifaceted and we show up with
different masks and different persona
you know for different situations and
you know for me I as an artist I I i
really like feeling like when i sit down
on stage and the closest version of my
authentic self and i'm showing the
audience the closest thing to
quote-unquote real that i can come up
with but you know it's still show
business yeah I still have to be onstage
at 7:00
and deliver a show no matter what's
going on and in order to do that I do
what anybody else who has to show up you
know to their job to deliver which is
like you know pull it together I'm
having a bad day you've got a cold like
pull it together at the show last night
I was thinking I had like conflicting
thoughts one was the way that you
carried yourself on stage and made
yourself comfortable created this sense
of intimacy where it really felt like we
were just in your living room hanging
out even though we're there's 1500
people there or whatever like that was
immediately established that level of
intimacy and just the just just the
relaxed demeanor that you had and the
way that the show unfolded felt like
very spontaneous like it just occurred
to you in the moment you were just
channeling whatever inspiration came to
you in that instance and then I thought
yeah but she's on tour like there's like
I'm sure the show varies a little bit
from evening to evening but essentially
she's doing the same thing over and over
and over again and having to you know
try to keep it fresh but also there's
some rehearsed aspect to it of course
yeah so when I was putting this show
together I am first of all I was
incredibly inspired seeing Hannah
Gatsby's show which I saw in London and
I'm I don't know if you've seen it yeah
having you should you should see it she
um she brought a level of authenticity
to that performance that I just never
quite seen before
and you know her show is purportedly a
stand-up show and she sort of goes met
us stand up and she explains comedy and
she explains laughter and how it's a
physical release and how she is used
laughter and she talks about trauma and
you know and she's a per aureus ly funny
and then at a certain point in the show
she tells you about being raped and the
laughter just stops and she she allows
it to stop
and then this whole room this whole
group sort of goes through it could have
a cataclysmic experience of having to
sit with the discomfort mmm of not being
able to laugh right in in in defiance of
all expectations yeah what this kind of
show was supposed to be like and then
and then she just doesn't let up and uh
watching her you know I thought a lot
about her watching the show I sort of
knew her from Australia and from Twitter
and I'd asked her if she wanted to get
together after the show and she says I
she wrote back to me and she said I just
I just don't after this show I need to
be not with people mm-hmm and you know
when I first got that message I was like
a pretentious and then I saw the show
and was like I get it I get how you
wouldn't want a code-switch and then
five minutes later being you know
chatting in the greenery about this that
any other thing and I've actually had to
deal with my own version of that
experience after this show I find it
really hard after doing this show to
just be bubbly and sociable and I still
do it every night but it like an energy
I mean in addition into it being four
hours just the emotional toll of having
to share you know so openly and honestly
and vulnerable about you know the
abortions and all these things that have
happened to you like night after night
after night it's gotta be well there's
also a way in which it's really
therapeutic mmm and it actually it's
like I leave a little bit lighter every
single night and one of the other things
I was gonna mention about the scripted
'no siz that watching Hanna's show was a
reminder having built my own TED talk
actually sort of set me off on this path
but we we have this crazy idea as indie
rockers especially that that scripted is
bad that it really needs to feel that
like every night you know even if you've
got the same setlist your banter between
songs needs
to just be totally off-the-cuff and
fresh and new and if you're telling a
story you just sort of making it up as
you go along so that everybody feels
comfortable because this is not theater
you know this is a rock show and I I had
to jump that hurdle for this show and
remember that doing this show more or
less scripted and it's not really
scripted I mean their beats in the show
and I improvised a lot of the stories
but that's allowed and that that that's
actually a kindness to the audience
because otherwise the show would be
seven and horrors well also you have
these people's attention for a certain
period of time and you have an intention
and something that you want to convey
how do you do that most effectively and
concisely like you have to ya know where
you want to take them and the best way
to get there well when I really learned
that with my TED talk because when I was
first putting my TED talk together I had
this naive belief that I would just
loosely script it but then I would be my
charming spontaneous self and that I had
to be my charming spontaneous self in
order to be real and I learned very
quickly that that was the least generous
performance I could give but actually
the best performance I could give was to
absolutely script that [ __ ] down
to the second and to every word and
every adjective so that I could deliver
you know the the most bang for the buck
with the 12 minutes that I had with
these people I wanted to take you to put
that together how long did it yeah I
mean it was it was effectively it was a
12 minute monologue that I had to
memorize and I had to have it memorized
inside out up down backwards and
forwards so I worked on that TED talk
for two solid night yeah well 12 minutes
is infinitely harder than an hour and a
half oh yeah yeah there's just no no
room for any for anything right yeah and
even after all of that rehearsal it's
still veered towards 13 minutes yeah
but you you talk about creating in these
I see you is this person who kind of
creates inverse and flurries like you
like
thing and I just bang this song out or I
had two hours and it was the best song I
ever wrote like what is that process
like for you like the writing process
and the creative inspiration aspect of
like how you you know make the things in
in which sense in the sense that do you
have like a discipline where you're like
I show up for the page every day
sometimes I don't have it or you're just
you get struck by lightning and you have
this gift or this facility and it just
pours out of you
it's changed over time actually so I
used to just wander around getting
struck by lightning constantly like you
know 10 times a day and occasionally I
would grab that lightning and run it
over to the piano and start a song but I
was very very bad at finishing songs and
I and I always carried around a lot of
guilt that I was great at starting songs
but bad at finishing them and finishing
a song is no fun
starting a songs really fun you know you
know it's sort of like a relationship
it's like that first few days of like
really hot sex and then like oh and then
you have to actually work on the
relationship that's just no fun you want
to keep you have problems and I I
finally about three years ago realized
that if I was going to get songs
finished that I should really just
follow the formula that seemed to be
presenting itself to me anyway which I
was which is you know seeing that the
best songs I had ever written were all
written in one sitting and I and I
wasn't very good at going back to a song
unless it was about 70 or 80 percent
done I just started sectioning off time
and you know knowing that lightning is
pretty much available to me I mean I can
turn on inspiration like a faucet you
know give me an instrument and I can
write a song yeah that's not a problem
it's really just a question of can I
finish
[ __ ] so writer's block is not a thing
yeah I've never had writer's about that
I mean I think writer's block can be
confused for other things you can always
write something it might just be bad
yeah you can always write something I
think it's a fear it's a fear thing it's
a fear of thinking you know you're not
good enough or yeah and I mean judge
perfectionism is definitely the enemy of
creation yeah and so lately you know
what I have found is really helpful is I
just have these blocks of time I also
have a kid now so I really have to
commit to you know a block of time
because my time is just not my own
anymore it belongs to my family
and I sit down and instead of vaguely
pondering is this idea really the one
that I want to follow I guess I could
like I just have stopped being
wishy-washy and I go with the first
thought and I follow it and I you know I
really shove perfectionism out the door
and I just I just try to finish the
thing mm-hmm and I think there's also a
luxury that comes with being an artist
who has made a lot of [ __ ] because once
you've made a lot of [ __ ] you're not so
precious about each and every little
offering because there's thousands of
them out there yeah when you've only
offered the world five or ten songs you
know any given song is going to be a
huge percentage of your catalog so
you're way more precious about it but
once you've proven yourself time and
time again you've written hundreds of
great songs like whether or not this
next song is the best thing you've ever
written isn't very important yeah yeah
yeah you want it if you you still hope
if you are if you are gonna do a second
TED talk though
right like because that was such a
sensation write it that it's like that
that one-hit-wonder thing like can I
repeat that can I get catch lightning in
a bottle again would be probably a
different well I would never do oh my
god yeah give me give me another I mean
I've got ten TED talks I could do I'd
love to do a TED talk
patronage yeah and the relationship over
time through history and into the future
about our lack of imagination around
helping each other I'd love to give its
head talk about miscarriage I'd love to
give a TED talk about childbirth I'd
love to give it TED talk about the
stupid rules around breastfeeding like I
could just go on and on enough I just
don't really want to do that right now
yeah well can we talk about patronage
though we can talk about anything yeah
like I said at the outset like your
relationship with your audiences is like
something I've never seen before
and it really and I've heard you speak
about this like your how you think about
the how you think about patronage and
the relationship is unique but it's also
more ancient right like what's what's
not functional is the relationship of
industry to artists now and how we think
about what that exchange looks like and
yours is one of depth and not over
breadth right where the industry kind of
is driven by breadth in terms of like
how big is your audience how many can
you sell and all of that rather than the
intimacy and the connection that you can
create with the people that are super
into what you're doing sure because
capitalism I mean we're all it's just
like what's going on with the rest of
the country and the problems that we're
running into everywhere which is it's
not about it's not always about growth
it's not always about being the biggest
and the best and you know where we've
really been fed a painfully unhealthy
diet of unsustainable ways of being and
that all of that applies to the art
world elaborate I mean I grew up
watching MTV that was my education and
what it meant to be a performer and a
musician
you know I was like raised on at the
altar of Prince and Madonna and
the Michael Jackson and you know these
massive mega stars were you know my
guiding light like that's where you're
supposed to head be massive that's
that's what success looks like I didn't
have many models even in my immediate
little community of musicians just
making a living you know musicians just
helping out their tribe their tribe
members with you know small helpful
connective reflections of what life in
this town was like of what you know what
we are going through now and you know
wind the clock back a little bit and
that's how human beings have been using
art and music for thousands of years
this scale thing that we have just been
experiencing in this teeny sliver of
human time is bananas well we we forget
and this is what you reminded me of is
that we forget that art and music really
had nothing to do with commerce no and
and and we're never supposed to yeah art
and music for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years of human history
were just useful tools of the tribe yeah
we needed it for ritual for grieving for
transition for celebration none of that
was about selling [ __ ] right there's
about doing and being and connecting and
so how did how do you think we lost that
initially I mean you get capitalism and
money in the mix and things start to get
very weird very fast yeah but we're in
this interesting time now where you know
in the MTV era you're look you're either
you either have a video on MTV or you're
on the radio or nobody could possibly
have any sense of what you were doing
yeah that's all changed everything has
been disintermediated the middle men and
the gatekeepers are now gone everybody
can be a creator and distribute their
wares worldwide and you know the the
the possibility that you can be this
massive band that you know that that
isn't even really a reality except for a
few acts these days anyway so it's
always true I mean and what I have found
fascinating is how little things have
changed because I think it's foolhardy
to say that the the the gatekeepers are
gone
they've just shifted faces and you know
we still have our mega pop stars they're
just you know the gates have just sort
of changed materials and you know in
this era we still have massive Stadium
pop stars and giant machines and we you
know we just we've just sort of shifted
the way those people climb up the
ladders and they climb to the top of the
mountain but they still climb to the top
of the mountain right but I think that
the infrastructure is still fractured
you know like you said in your book like
we are the media like that's a radical
concept that's also very true and we're
still in the very early stages of that
but it's undeniable you know with you
leading the charge and we're seeing more
and more people kind of blaze this the
past similar to yours that this is the
future like finding your tribe and
honoring that is the path yeah and I
mean I I adopted the internet really
early on as a community tool but none of
us saw any of this stuff coming you know
none of us back in you know 2000 2005
era could have forecasted that in 2019
we would be talking about deep fakes and
talking about you know and looking at a
generation of kids who it's very
possible we'll never trust an image yeah
or even a moving image because who knows
if that image is really real and their
cultural literacy their media literacy
is gonna be so different from yours and
mine you know we grew up in an era where
like if you saw someone saying and on a
TV it was obviously happen yeah that's
not true anymore
yeah so playing that out like what does
that look like
very strange
I mean I don't know and if I had the
answer oh my god like that would be my
TED talk I don't have an answer um but I
do think you know it's all good for me
with music and art it's always gonna
circle back to why we needed it in the
first place the platforms will change
who we trust will change the middlemen
will change the gatekeepers the filters
will change but why we do it and why we
need to feel it that will not change no
nor will the expression you know the the
the impulse to say something and the
appetite for story and art and people
who are who are grappling with trying to
find meaning in this crazy thing that
we're doing called life right amen yeah
that's not going away yeah out of
curiosity it was interesting that you
did your book with a traditional
publisher because I would have thought
like of all people like why didn't you
self publish it but I really thought
about that
um because I got a lot of attention and
a lot of offers and people knocking on
my door after the TED talk mm-hmm and I
knew that I already had a big audience
and that I had attended that you know
that garden very meticulously and I had
a great relationship with my crowd and
that if I wrote a book they would
absolutely be on board to buy it
directly from me and I knew that I could
do that if I wanted but I had also sort
of raced that course once with with
music publishing and and um basically
starting my own record label and I know
that it is not uncomplicated to learn
how to do an entire industry out of your
own office out of your own bedroom and I
knew that book publishing was probably
just as complicated if not more
complicated than record record release
so I knew that there was and I just knew
that there was a glass ceiling there so
was I capable of like
finding an editor writing a book making
a cover binding it mailing it out to
25,000 people
I was probably capable of doing that did
I want to learn how to do all of those
things and do them really well and then
also probably you know not necessarily
be able to find a good distributor for
that book to get it in bookstores all
over the world and get it translated and
then have people know that that book was
out and I was like let someone else do
that yeah well I think also it it boils
down to your intention to like if you
wrote the book just to serve your
audience that's one thing but but when
you go with the publisher you have the
opportunity to broaden that aperture a
little bit and and reach people that
might not know you are yeah and it and
it works
I mean I um I stand by that decision and
it is really rewarding to see someone in
Russia or China you know picking up my
book translated into another language
connecting with the ideas you know
coming back to me and don't telling me
on Twitter that something that I said
shifted something for them or changed
their life and I don't think that would
have happened if I had published the
book myself yeah
can we talk about asking no no we're not
gonna talk about that I asked I know
that's why I was money yeah you know
there's this this idea that like you're
the you're the DIY queen like
do-it-yourself queen but it's not about
doing it yourself this out it's it's the
exact opposite of that I try to explain
this in the book that DIY is it's such a
misnomer yeah you know what it really
means DIY especially you know as applied
to the world that I came out of like the
punk world and stuff DIY was you know we
will do it we're not gonna use the
system do it without the system what
would have probably been a better
acronym but not as sexy tell the story
about Thoreau and donuts
I think that captures it that's a great
story yeah I so I actually heard that
story someone else gave a talk at the
at the exo conference and I saw that
talk and actually wrote to him to ask if
I could steal the anecdote whose very
upsetting to me so uh Henry Thoreau and
you know especially Walden he's he's
seen as this American hero of
do-it-yourself go off grid connect with
nature self-reliance right and you know
and everyone knows who's read Walden her
knows this sort of piece of American
history he went and built his own little
shack on the side of Walden Pond and
just like everyone knows the quotes
right mm-hmm I went to the woods because
I wished to live deliberately I wanted
to suck the marrow out of life and
everyone is just like haha you know punk
rock you know you just did you know did
it himself picked his own food you know
like what well actually it's [ __ ] he
was so helped and he did have his little
cabin by the woods and he was sort of
off-grid but also he's a total
freeloader and he was constantly going
over to Emerson's house where they had
great dinners and he was just constantly
welcomed in and hosted and the doughnuts
story is the best his mom and his sister
every Sunday would bring him a basket of
doughnuts it's so crushing to hear that
spoiled child but also you know I take
it one level further in the book so
there's a few things about Walden that
are really beautiful one is he'd
actually lived at Walden for three years
but he condensed the story for you know
the story of Walden is one year he
condensed it down he took huge artistic
liberties with his memoir to deliver you
know again like something economically
palatable that we could flow with and
understand he was an artist he took the
experience and he made art and he left
out the story about the [ __ ]
doughnuts
it just wouldn't have squared with the
Walden brand right but when you look at
it that the book worked
Walden worked people got on board with
the idea they felt him they got it it's
not that walden is inauthentic but we
can also look back and ask well like
what what fuel fed his ability to send
that message into the world into the
Canon of American literature and the
donuts are part of that mmm
the generosity of Emerson and his mother
and his sister and all the townspeople
who just thought he was a kook but
helped him out like they fed that vision
is Walden authentic you know maybe by
some measure it's not maybe there's like
a little bit of early American charlatan
in there or maybe it's just art and art
is never getting back to this
conversation from earlier it's never
totally pure it doesn't work that way an
artist usually has a vision and then you
know does whatever he or she has to do
to to create this offering and it's
always messy always yeah there's a
distinction between truth and fact right
like the artists job is to extract the
truth out of you know a certain
perspective and that doesn't mean
fidelity to a factual timeline it's
about trying to discern from an
experience what is universal so to take
that 3 years and condense it to one to
speak to something that he was
passionate about
I don't think diminishes the work that
he did well it is interesting you know
because you know part of part of that
legacy is you know Americana like rugged
individualism your bootstraps and
do-it-yourself and and it it you know
it's a lie
simply because everybody has relied on
everybody else well in life is right in
the world I mean look at Trump's story
about himself as compared to what we now
know is the truth love or whatever the
truth is so can I possibly know it
self-made billionaire self-made
billionaire it's all just [ __ ]
mm-hmm but God his own belief in his
story and his ability to just
unapologetically stick to his story is
what I think people find so incredibly
attractive well and larger than that
it's it's it's this sensibility that we
have that that's what's to be celebrated
like we celebrate that that rugged
individualism and the person that
doesn't have to raise their hand and ask
for help and did it by themselves is
this fabrication that you know we've
decided is laudable and what we should
aspire to and it's insane yeah I mean
from you know you point out like well
you look at Steve Jobs like his parents
had to give him the garage right nobody
who didn't you know who didn't advance
without the help of whoever well and to
think that we're supposed to do this
life without help without being
interconnected is insanity
hmm yeah I mean I you know I grew up
like a lot of people you know intuitive
at might I mean my dad I vividly
remember you know going on family
vacations in the station wagon and my
dad getting lost and refusing to ask for
directions and just getting into fights
with my mom because he just would not go
to the gas station and that's the guy
where to go and you know that's the you
know emotional landscape that I
inherited yeah and you know as you point
out in your book like this is this is
you know right in the in the wheelhouse
of brené Brown like this idea that you
know to ask for help is to show
vulnerability which in men you know is
very shame provoking
it makes us feel like failures and in
women and makes them feel like they're
not enough to raise their hands
yeah whereas if you if you just do a
quarter turn you could look at every
potential for asking for help as an
opportunity to connect which is what we
actually like you know this is the this
is I write about this in the art of
asking when you start asking and you
take the charge and the shame out of it
life becomes really bountiful because
people generally like being asked you
know I mean the gas station attendant
who only gets asked maybe not so much
but people really like feeling useful
people like sharing knowledge people
like sharing period I mean it's the
other side of the myth that you know the
why would you ask for help why would you
ask for someone to share their thing why
would you want to do that well that's
actually how we function best you know
is as a community as a tribe is an
interconnected tribe you do that I'll do
this you know we'll we'll figure this
out together
none of us clearly you know look at us
from the early days of our mammal hood
we're not were not rugged individuals we
were not physically built to walk
through this life alone no way no how
this is not the way were constructed
were built as tribal beings who were
supposed to be interconnected and
interdependent that's literally how
we're built and so fighting that is just
a form of self annihilation yeah and yet
that sensibility is what has driven I
think this epidemic of loneliness and
isolation and everybody you know living
in their ticky-tack house is separate
from each other and non-communicative
and and ultimately depressed and but
this all began with you like like for
you you know when I think of your story
like it all starts with you making eye
contact
with one individual in Harvard Square
it's like that intimate connection
really created the foundation for
everything that you do now can you talk
about that a little bit well you're
talking about when I was a street
performer um so I was a street performer
for a lot of my early 20s and I was a
living statue and I had a lot of great
intimate moments with many many many
many strangers um but in the cause and
effect of my life I'm not sure that that
was the cause of where I had it after
that so much as you know that was
something that but I like it the sorry I
don't want to project on you at all but
like that idea yeah like you talked
about you know making eye contact with
people and like and and seeing them like
in the value of like being seen right
and that seems to be a theme that
resonates throughout how you interact
with your audience today yeah like your
willingness to see that well I think you
could um you could probably find an
answer to my you know why I had a hunger
for being seen as I think we all really
do but you know it might have been
amplified in me because I was the
youngest of four kids and I also I for a
lot of reasons felt very unseen as a kid
and also had a talent for performing and
for music and loved the stage and I
really grappled with a lot of pain and
agony as a teenager and into my early
twenties about my desire to be seen
because I had been really punished by a
lot of different adults for wanting to
be seen like I got smacked around for
wanting to be seen and told that I was
that I was being distracting that I was
just trying to get attention that it
wasn't all about me and so I constantly
second-guessed and was suspicious of my
own desire to be
see nor my desire for any attention
because I was afraid of it and I was
afraid that it was wrong and bad and so
it wasn't until I really started
performing and connecting with people on
a on a profound level that I got to sort
of smooth those rough edges away and
actually see my desire to be seen as a
positive force instead of as this like
terrible negative need yeah and where
did the this when did you kind of begin
to really form this sensibility around
asking what do you mean give me
something more specific you know when
when you when you give your TED talk
it's so eloquently you know kind of
considered but was there like a moment
where you realize like this is the path
for me is is laid out in my willingness
to you know rely upon these people as
patrons of you know what I do I mean I
think a lot of it I just picked up from
the music communities and the art
communities that I wanted to emulate and
the music and art communities that I
wanted to emulate were the were the
interconnected ones the ones where I saw
people helping each other where it was
about the music and about the connection
about the togetherness and about the
progress and the evolution and the you
know the folk scene uh-huh that was all
based on like brothers and sisters let's
hold hands and do this together let's
try to share our truths let's try to
affect change the punk scene was the
same way the punk scene was about like
forget about those people like we'll do
this we have truths to tell we will do
shows in basements we will you know
we'll carry around our own gear we will
help each other do this and we don't
need the system
and those were the scenes that I
gravitated towards and the and the
people and the systems that I wanted to
emulate and those systems were based on
asking they were based on asking like do
you have an amp I can borrow can we use
your basement will you come to my show
will you go will you get on your bike
with me and go around town with duct
tape and fliers and put signs up like
let's do this lets us do that right and
the answer always being yes yeah because
it's fun right yeah I mean one of the
things you talk about is is you know
this initial desire to be a rockstar and
then realizing like well rockstars are
the antithesis of what I want to be
because they're isolated those nuts
they're disconnected well and now we can
actually you know we didn't have a
control back then but we can now look at
some of my heroes from the you know days
of MTV as alter and you know Michael
Jackson my hero and Prince my hero and
Madonna whatever the jury's out on
Madonna who knows if she's happy but I
think we can say with some degree of
certainty that those guys were not very
happy that being up on Rockstar Mountain
disconnected and unable to just be among
and with the tribe did not make those
guys happy well and because happiness is
a direct function of your connectivity
to the tribe totally right and that's
like you're I mean you're immersed it's
like your life is crowd-surfing
with these people that holds you up yeah
yeah yeah and I mean in the and then the
question there becomes like well is that
is that scalable mm-hmm and that's sort
of scalable for yourself or other people
you before anyone yeah why why wouldn't
it be why why I mean there's got to be
Legion of you know young Amanda Palmer's
out there at the early in the early
stages of creating what you've created
sure and then the question is you know
can you hold that level of intimacy and
that level of connectivity to the tribe
and the normalcy that is required of you
and the tribe in order for you to just
stand there when you're playing to an
arena of 30,000 people do you worry
about that no because I don't think I'm
ever gonna be playing people but if you
were to I mean has that thought crossed
your mind like I don't want to be that
big because I don't want to lose that
connection I I like to thank
optimistically that if I lived in a
universe in which this kind of music
attracted a crowd of 30,000 people we'd
be living in a universe where I would be
okay well I mean you can't fake it
either like that that you know that love
that you have for your tribe is visceral
right it's not something you can be fake
and I and you know we'll look you know
even these words vulnerability and and
community and connectivity like they've
been co-opted these have been
commercialized like there is a it's like
on social media there's a there's a
there's a performative vulnerability
like people who are like you know sort
of oversharing but really kind of just
build their audience or get clicks like
it doesn't feel real like there's a
certain lack of lack of authenticity in
this seemingly quote-unquote authentic
post right yeah I mean do you notice
that you see that yeah so there's a
different there's a there's a difference
between the rete they're the real thing
and kind of this rise of you know yeah
and I mean the you'll you'll get back
what you put out you know you can't
really get away with faking your head
and for a good reason
you know because you just can't yeah and
it won't feed you back if you put out
empty calories you're not gonna you're
not going to be nurtured in return yoga
meditation
I'm a fan yeah what is the relationship
between those things and kind of your
creative sensibility like how does it
feel that oh well I am I started my yoga
and meditation practice and an earnest
in my early 20s and I don't I don't
think you can disentangle any of my
career and my path from my practice I
yeah I just I don't have another one of
me who didn't do that so I'll never know
right but I you know I credit my my
mindfulness practice to you know any of
the insights that I've had about any of
this stuff probably wouldn't have
happened and what does that practice
look like it depends on it depends on
the time to be great well I just had a
child so one of the first things that
went out the window was my morning
meditation mmm because child mm-hmm
but I still ice it when I can I try to
go to yoga when I can and I you know I
also am I'm a firm believer that the
that you practice off the mat they you
know that you just try to live mindfully
and that it's possible at any time it's
possible during a podcast it's possible
while brushing your teeth it's possible
it's possible while driving a car and
actually the danger is in separating and
thinking that your practice is you know
when you're sitting in lotus position
being all you know meditating and you
take it into the world yeah I mean
that's the only point of the practice
isn't it right but I was lucky you know
in my in my early 20s my mentor Anthony
he gifted and assured me into meditation
retreats and those were galvanizing
experiences
doing silent meditation retreats in my
20s for you know six seven days at a
times like the opossum our retreats
uh-huh yeah yeah and that also you know
that plus a regular yoga practice in my
20s you know I just had the proof right
there that when I practiced I was more
able to deal with life and when I didn't
I wasn't mm-hmm and I knew you know I
could either go left or I could go right
and I chose to go towards practice yeah
so we're in an interesting moment right
now with reproductive rights and
everything that's going on in Georgia
and I'm interested in and how you know
how you see the future of the female
empowerment movement and how you see
your role in that and and you know what
what what the next generation of this
looks like I was that for like a really
broad back I wish I had an answer I have
I have hopes yeah you know it's it may
get worse before it gets better
um but I'm starting to see people rising
up standing up speaking out organizing
like I have not seen before and it's
going to be an amazing yeah it's it's
like so many other things happening
right now I mean there's going to have
to be a revolutionary push back against
the climate disaster there's going to
have to be a revolutionary pushback
against you know the human rights
violations whether it's reproductive or
you know what what is happening with
immigration like there is going to have
to be a pendulum swing as hard and as
you know and as powerful as as the one
that's taken us into the dark and the
you know the world is moving really fast
right now everything just feels like is
going a
sort of a critical urgent speed and I I
hope I can sense I might be wrong but in
the art and music world especially when
it comes to reproductive rights and
women that you are going to start to see
stories coming out at an alarming rate
because it is that it is the sharpest
weapon we have right now you know and we
can take political action of this kind
or that but actually the most important
thing women can do right now is just get
up and shamelessly tell their stories
tell the truth yeah I mean that's that's
what your show is all about right like
in you doing this and showing look I'm
gonna share this like it gives everybody
else permission to do the same and it's
you know it's visceral and it's powerful
to hear that coming from you and you
know as a as a white man to really
understand like the universality of this
kind of story that you told last night
and how many people are impacted by it
and from it and sharing it in that kind
of very first-person experience or kind
of way like this is what it's like when
you have to like go on Google and find
where the place is and then you got
again like are you supposed to call
anyone like what are you supposed to do
like to really like walk in those shoes
to feel what that must feel like
yeah and to remind people the
information is power you know and the
the history books don't lie I mean we
can look at it across time when when
fascism is on the rise anywhere in the
world the first thing to go is
reproductive rights mm-hmm it's just
hand in hand that's the way it works and
never has there been you know that's
when the the role and the importance of
the artist kind of gets yeah it's our
storage it's our job just get up and go
like oh god we don't really want to have
to do this yeah we'd so much rather be
doing
things but like [ __ ] this yeah this is
not good for us
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this alright I think
that's it get you to the airport um
thank you thank you for everything to do
keep making all the things I can't help
it
alright cool talk to you soon thank you
peace
[Music]